à
premier débat télévisé de la campagne
présidentielle pas de vainqueur et un
vaincu la technique le cnpf d'accord
pour lutter contre l'inflation aux côtés
du gouvernement mais pas à n'importe
quel prix
kissinger a convaincu une ronde et sia
les noirs au pouvoir dans un délai de
deux ans
l'évêque d'autun pour l'ouverture de
l'église aux divorcés remariés les
déchets la société peuvent-ils nous
sauver ce sera l'objet de notre dossier
m haies messieurs bonsoir 100 millions
d'américains étaient devant leur écran
et hier soir leur écran de télévision et
le monde entier tendait l'oreille vers
philadelphie pour le premier des trois
débats télévisés entre gerald ford et
jimmy carter avant les élections
présidentielles américaines avec airtel
nous avions ici à antenne 2 retransmis
en direct ce premier face à face des
deux candidats pour un public de
spécialistes mais vous avez pu vous même
juger de la performance du président des
états unis et de l'ancien gouverneur de
géorgie puisque nous avons diffusé entre
12h15 et 13h30 aujourd'hui de larges
extraits du débat
à dire vrai la plupart des observateurs
sont un peu déçus jimmy carter n'a pas
crevé l'écran comme on dit et comme on
pouvait l'espérer et gerald ford n'a
rien apporté de nouveau sur lui même ou
sur son programme politique dans ces
conditions il est bien difficile de dire
qui a remporté cette première manche
encore que l'on donne généralement un
léger avantage au président en exercice
reste que ce débat n'a pas eu tant s'en
fout la qualité et l'intensité du
célèbre duel nixon kennedy de 1960
et pourtant il restera sans doute dans
l'histoire pour une autre raison le
débat en direct a été interrompue
pendant 28 minutes à cause d'une panne
de son ce premier affrontement va donc
entrer dans la petite histoire les héros
malheureux il ya soir à philadelphie
n'ont été ni carter ni ford mais la
télévision américaine qu'on aurait cru
incapables de nous faire une chose
pareille
28 minutes d'interruption un camion
transmission en panne et 28 minutes d'un
spectacle imprévu sous les excuses de
nos confrères présentateur américain est
sous les projecteurs que vous pouvez
couper ford et carter ont ainsi
travaillé leur maintien
le premier sans doute parce qu'il est le
président légèrement nerveux et sautant
d'un pied sur l'autre sans tomber le
second
carter s'accrochant son pipe comme une
prière ou à la présidence
bref du grand spectacle qu'on nous avait
refusé auparavant il est vrai que la
soirée était sérieuse puisque les deux
candidats par l'air de l'avenir des
américains de le pas de leur porte
monnaie
fiscalité emploi énergie jimmy carter
n'a pas connu de défaillance mais ces
arguments n'ont pas bouleversé et
réellement inquiéter gerald ford
le président des états unis avait lancé
le défi on peut dire que carter n'a pas
relevé le gant de manière irréfutable
les supporters du président les
républicains peuvent donc penser
aujourd'hui que gerald ford n'est pas un
peu plus mauvais gestionnaires que son
rival prochain chapitre
le 6 octobre à san francisco avec la
politique étrangère et une heure trente
de débat sans interruption d'une petite
erreur de titres n'étaient pas graves
aux états unis et on s'en est bien rendu
compte dans les élections
présidentielles de ces quinze dernières
années c'est vraiment la télévision ou
plus exactement l'image que l'opinion se
fait des candidats au travers de la
télévision qui fait la décision il est
donc intéressant de savoir comment les
américains ont perçu ce premier face à
face entre gerald ford et jimmy carter
ici à washington on est plutôt déçu pour
le pâlir frustré après ce débat qui
devait être historique et qui n'a rien
prouvé rapide sondage d'opinion donnent
il est vrai le président faure gagnant
probablement parce qu'on attendait mieux
de jimmy carter mais à aucun moment je
n'ai senti le souffle
l'argument la phrase qui pourrait
emporter l'adhésion des électeurs
américains les journaux l'ont plus
d'ailleurs qui comme le washington post
se borne à retracer ce matin le fils
d'un match sans grandeur dans les nôtres
des candidats avaient pourtant les
cartouches dans la poche
ford capitaine courageux qui a pris la
barre après la tempête de watergate
l'homme de la confiance
carter l'archange d'un monde nouveau
poussé lui par le besoin de changement
la résurrection de l'amérique rien j'en
n'ai rien retrouvé de tous deux
candidats bien sage prudent soucieux
avant tout de ne pas effrayer le p ils
ont sans doute raison
il faut comprendre au stade où en sont
les élections américaines que l'enjeu
n'est pas comme en europe
un choix de société quel que soit le
vainqueur
l'amérique ne basculera pas ford et
carter ont le même catéchisme il croit
au capitalisme à la libre entreprise et
à la vertu de la concurrence à partir de
là les choix ne sont que des nuances
le débat d'hier a montré que l'on votera
plus sur le prix du bifteck que sur le
scandale du watergate la politique
étrangère ou la sécurité sociale bien
des événements peuvent c'est vrai
dramatiser cette campagne électorale qui
ne fait que commencer
il serait tenté de dire ce soir que
l'amérique est en train de se désigner
un vaincu plutôt que de se choisir un
grand vainqueur
raymond barre le premier ministre a
passé encore cette journée a organisé la
mise en oeuvre de son plan anti
inflation en recevant en particulier le
directeur des prix un certain nombre de
personnalités et puis aussi tous les
préfets y compris ceux d'outre-mer
valéry giscard d'estaing lui qui
mercredi prochain vous le savez à la
télévision et à antenne 2 donnera au
plan anti inflation le label
présidentielle recevra à déjeuner lundi
les trois ministres d'état messieurs
richard poniatowski et le canot est
vraisemblablement pour préparer la
rentrée parlementaire et notamment la
discussion du plan et du budget
aujourd'hui c'était monsieur françois
ceyrac le président du cnpf qui était
reçu à l'elysée françois ceyrac venait
chercher quelques informations
complémentaires sans doute mais surtout
confirmé au président de la république
que les chefs d'entreprise soutiendrait
le plan dans l'intérêt général
je lui ai donc dit que nous étions
d'accord pour soutenir le plan barre
même si certaines modalités calme
blocage des prix de nous plaisent guère
d'eux que il était nécessaire de se
pencher sur le problème du redressement
économique de ce pays
redressement économique qui n'est pas
achevée qui est en panne et qu'il faudra
par conséquent nécessairement poursuivre
est ce que le plan barre selon vous va
avoir des conséquences identiques pour
les grandes entreprises ou les pme parce
qu'il ya quand même quelques différences
fondamentalement le problème économique
posée par l'inflation est le même pour
tous les français et pour toutes les
entreprises
mais dans la pratique il est certain que
les capacités des petites entreprises ou
des moyennes entreprises à s'adapter
instantanément ou à supporter
instantanément certaines mesures très
contraignantes sont moins fortes
ça pose des problèmes particuliers aux
petites et moyennes entreprises et je
souhaite beaucoup que l'état dans
l'application de ce plan est une
attention particulière pour les
entreprises petites et moyennes françois
ceyrac
dans son plan anti inflation le
gouvernement a demandé aux chefs
d'entreprises d'être particulièrement
vigilant cette année sur les salaires
alors pensez vous que les patrons vont
jouer le jeu c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont
pas préféré lâcher sur les salaires pour
se préserver de grève et conserver la
paix sociale les patrons joueront le jeu
en ce qui concerne les prix ils
respecteront les consignes
gouvernementales et une respecteront
également le plan en ce qui concerne les
salaires le c'est un tout on ne peut pas
dissocier ce plan accepté les salaires
et refuser les prix ou inversement
demain dans le journal de jean lundi à
13h jean-jacques servan-schreiber pour
la première fois donnera quelque sorte
un prolongement au débat qui s'est
engagé immédiatement après l'annoncé du
plan anti inflation jean-jacques
servan-schreiber qui a fait sa rentrée
ce matin au comité directeur du parti
radical qu'il boudait depuis de longs
mois et auquel participaient les quatre
leaders radicaux aux membres du
gouvernement
d'accord at on dit place de valois pour
se planter inflation conjoncturel mais
il est temps de s'attaquer aux
structures aux causes même de
l'inflation à noter que les radicaux ont
remise à la mode le manifeste de
jean-jacques servan-schreiber a prouvé
en son temps par les amis de robert
fabre aujourd'hui signataires du
programme comme françois mitterrand
n'était pas sans doute en possession de
cette information lorsqu'il hier soir il
est arrivé à roissy venant de londres
pour le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste il n'est pas question de
pratiquer la politique du pire il faut
discerner dans le plan ce qui est bien
et ce qui est mal
tel qu'il m'apparaît à première lecture
son plan est un ensemble de mesures un
peu disparate plaqué sur une réalité
sociale injuste réalité à laquelle on ne
tente pas de remédier et cela aggrave
donc les inégalités et frappe le plus
grand nombre notamment les salariés
je ne vois pas comment toujours sous
bénéfice d'inventaire je ne vois pas
comment de telles mesures pourraient
obtenir le consentement nationales
réclamée par le premier ministre nous ne
pouvons que souhaiter la réussite d'une
politique qui permettrait au français de
vivre mieux simplement nous n'y croyons
pas dans les conditions présentes encore
une réaction au plan barre celle des pme
des petites et moyennes entreprises
monsieur gingembre le président des pme
n'est pas très content nous avons
l'impression dit il d'être les sacrifier
une fois de plus c'est ce qu'il a
déclaré aujourd'hui l'une des conditions
essentielles en tout cas elle est
importante pour que le plan barre
réussisse et que le blocage des prix
soit réel donc que le contrôle des prix
soit efficace l'objectif du ministère
des finances est temps de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour atteindre une hausse 0 0 2
dans les trois mois qui viennent c'est
ce que monsieur vilain le directeur des
prix révèle ce soir courante end
jusqu'au 31 décembre 1976
les prix doivent rester au niveau qu'ils
avaient atteint le 15 septembre dernier
et cela à tous les stades de la
production et de la distribution
il n'y a qu'une exception il faut en
prévenir d'ores et déjà les
consommateurs ce sont les produits
agricoles frais dont nous ne pouvons pas
geler les prix à la production en raison
des règles communautaires
ces produits agricoles frais sont très
limités ce sont les viandes les fruits
et légumes
certains produits laitiers et le 20 mai
de personnes font ces contrôles pour
vérifier que les étiquettes ne bouge pas
les effectifs de la direction générale
des prix sont-ce en province dans les
départements de 2100 personnes mais à
cet effectif de mes fonctionnaires
proprement dit doivent s'ajouter tous
les fonctionnaires de police et
notamment à paris la police économique
où les effectifs sont assez importants
puisque la direction la plus économique
est capable de mettre 300 personnes sur
le terrain à paris à cela s'ajoutent les
services de gendarmerie que le ministère
des armes et s'engagent à nous prêter et
en ce qui concerne les finances mon
collègue le directeur général des
douanes a d'ores et déjà envoyé un telex
à six directeurs régionaux pour que les
douaniers nous donne un coup de main
dans cette affaire que monte la garde
auprès des étiquettes non les gendarmes
ne montrent pas la gare d'eau auprès des
étiquettes les gendarmes font des
relevés de prix et éventuellement ans
repasse au bout d'un certain temps pour
voir si les prix on bouge
les prix ont bougé les embâcles
gendarmes sont au même titre que mes
fonctionnaires habilités à dresser
procès verbal
aujourd'hui encore on ignorait les
détails de cette mobilisation générale
mobilisation contre les étiquettes dans
les magasins mais aussi contre les
hausses des services comme les
restaurants la coiffure ou les garages
que se passera t'il réellement sur le
terrain
la crainte des sanctions ne sera peut
être pas suffisantes pour empêcher la
malle d éthique est implanté à
l'inflation
c'est formidable pour les distributeurs
les distributeurs ils sont toujours les
gens dont on dit c'est tous les fauteurs
de hausse alors qu'en réalité on est
comme le consommateur les autres on les
subit vous savez nous mais tout le monde
savait et qu'il y aura un blocage des
prix vous n'avez pas été tenté avant de
hausser certains pays nos cieux dans une
entreprise comme nous semble sans
magasin vous rendez compte on a une
politique on lime les prix on compresse
les marges mais ça depuis le 1er janvier
jusqu'à la saint-sylvestre
on va approcher publicité mais ce que
maintenant qu'il ya la peur du gendarme
nous aide pas être tentée être un peu
plus rigoureux en black hat usa il est
sûr qu'un on sera sûrement face à des
gens qui seront peut-être fois très
compréhensif 1 parce que quand un
gendarme relève des prix en général
c'est pas très rigolo pour nous
à l'étranger on a beaucoup spéculé
aujourd'hui sur ces curieuses rumeurs à
propos de l'état de santé du roi hassan
ii du maroc une information en
provenance apparemment de l'ex sahara
espagnol annonçait que le roi subirait
prochainement à madrid une intervention
chirurgicale très sérieuse cette
nouvelle vous en doutez a provoqué une
cascade de démentis temps à rabat qu'à
madrid mais mystère tout même en afrique
du sud nouvelle journée d'émeutes cette
fois ci c'est en plein centre de
johannesburg que se sont produits les
affrontements les plus violents
sanglants même l'afrique du sud paradis
économique ce n'est pas si sûr guy
thomas dans son point de vue il
reviendra dans un instant mais ce soir
dans cette partie de l'afrique australe
temps agités et sous les projecteurs et
dont les projecteurs sont braqués sur
l'art au 10 6 millions de noirs et
quelques centaines de milliers de blanc
au pouvoir c'est peut-être une journée
historique en effet pour ce pays puisque
ian smith le premier ministre indien
vient d'accepter le plan kissinger c'est
à dire le principe de l'accession au
pouvoir de la majorité noire dans un
délai de deux ans et monsieur smith
vient de l'annoncer à son pays dans un
message radiodiffusé
bonsoir j'ai eu ces derniers jours des
entretiens très important à
johannesbourg avec le premier ministre
d'afrique du sud monsieur georges terre
et j'ai eu des entretiens également avec
monsieur qui siégèrent et j'ai dû
accepter le plan américain
bio télévisé que son gouvernement a
accepté le plan qui suggère c'est à dire
l'accession de la majorité noire au
pouvoir et ce dans un délai de deux ans
c'est bien sûr un changement radical de
politique en rhodésie la seule condition
qu'à exiger le premier ministre et que
cessent tous les combats dans le pays et
la guérilla aux frontières l'afrique du
sud l'amérique surtout ont aucune raison
de la détermination aveugle de monsieur
jan smith il se pourrait bien maintenant
que le premier ministre désire abdiqué
qu'il abandonne ses fonctions en faveur
d'un président de gouvernement
provisoire qui sera désigné par la
grande-bretagne la rhodésie était depuis
onze ans que le nid rebelles de la
grande bretagne
et c'est en 1965 que monsieur jan smith
et ses partisans choisi de proclamer
unilatéralement l'indépendance de la
rhodésie sous la responsabilité d'un
régime blanc local un pays qui compte
258 blanc et 6 millions noah et il est
clair après tout ça que le dernier
bastion plan en afrique est en train de
se fissurer et cela de plus en plus
rapidement à considérer ce qui s'est
passé en afrique du sud depuis moins
d'un an
rien ne semble devoir arrêter cet
éclatement tenait il ya six mois et
dirigeant d'une très grande société
française de distribution négocier un
accord avec une société de même nature
en afrique du sud la corée vries il
s'agissait dans un premier temps de
construire trois hypermarchés aux
français qui s'inquiétait des risques
d'émeutes les sud-africains répliquèrent
en toute bonne foi ces grandes surfaces
seront installés dans les sanctuaires
blanc rien à craindre pour leurs
vitrines
il ne pourrez plus dire la même chose
aujourd'hui après ce qui vient de se
passer à johannesburg il hier et à cape
town il y a deux semaines
cette insécurité grandissante à des
effets immédiates sur l'économie sud
africaine
les firmes étrangères hésitent
maintenant à investir dans ce pays les
riches sud africain tente de placer leur
fortune aux etats-unis ou en europe
en juillet dernier la balance
commerciale a marqué un déficit record
les exportations non couverts qu'à 58 %
les importations la crise prend de
sérieuses proportions aggraver encore
par la baisse du cours de l'or ressource
principale de ce pays baisse que
washington peut accentuer à sa guise en
sachant qu'au dessous d'un certain
niveau de prix la moitié des mines d'or
sud africaine ne serait plus rentable et
devrait fermer
déjà le nombre de chômeurs dépasse les 2
millions 25% de là
population noire active de la graine des
métiers pour les blancs 5 millions
contre 20 millions de gens de couleur
pour la communauté blanche qui avait mis
ses espoirs dans ses hélicoptères de
combat s'est plaint des ces bonbons
napalm bref un super armements
c'est le commencement de la fin des
illusions on ne peut braver à la fois
défini mans et la loi du nombre
et l'opinion universel décidément
l'église catholique en tout cas à
l'église de france n'a pas fini de nous
étonner de nous réserver les surprises
après monseigneur lefebvre et les ultras
traditionalistes voici mon seigneur le
bourgeois évêque d'autun et les ultra
moderne pour la première fois évêque
d'autun acceptent de parler pour antenne
2 de ses idées d'avant-garde il propose
ni plus ni moins de rompre avec la
tradition en permettant aux divorcés
remariés de recevoir la communion
ecoutez-le
l'église a effectivement une législation
qui actuel qui exclut les divorcés
remariés de la communion
je respecte cette législation il ne
m'appartient pas de la changer mais j'ai
le droit et à mon avis même le devoir
comme pasteur d'une église locale de
faire connaître la souffrance qu'ils
éprouvent un certain nombre de chrétiens
qui se voit ainsi exclue c'est pour ça
que je souhaiterais pour ma part que
dans certaines conditions précises
certains chrétiens puissent être admis
au sacrement de l'eucharistie
quelles conditions les conditions que
l'on peut déterminer nous en avons pas
mal de nous y avons pas mal réfléchi
avec les prêtres du diocèse c'est le
contenu de ma lettre
ce serait d'abord une situation disons
irréversible un foyer est fondée il ne
peut plus séparer les enfants ce moment
là par exemple
d'autre part une situation telle que ces
voiliers et pris leur place dans la
communauté chrétienne qu'ils aient donné
de signes par exemple de la justice à
l'égard de l'ancien conjoint et des
enfants d'un premier mariage que cela
arrive qu'il soit engagé dans la
communauté chrétienne d'une manière
telle que l'on puisse et ziad mettent
non pas comme à la sauvette
fait quelques fois mais officiellement
publiquement et je pense que c'est ma
manière dont l'église peut donner ce
signe de l'accueil personnellement je ne
comprendrais pas une église qui dirait
je vous demande de rester chez moi mais
je vous ignorent mêmes qui est encore je
vous invite à ma table mais je ne vous
donne pas à manger depuis un an au moins
que l'on vous parle économie d'économie
d'énergie vous avez peut-être pris
l'habitude
en tout cas c'est souhaitable de fermer
vos lumières lorsque vous n'êtes pas
dans une pièce de rouler un peu moins
vite en voiture de baisser votre
chauffage etc
ces conseils vous les connaissez mais
avez vous songé que vos déchets
pouvaient être source d'énergie
probablement pas et pourtant ces déchets
ces ordures le contenu de votre poubelle
même peut valoir
et oui de l'or
en principe un déchet c'est une perte
sèche on prend des matières premières
avec de l'énergie on les transforme on
fabrique des produits et puis le produit
est vendu utiliser consommer et il s'use
à la fin de sa vie il est jeté
souvent polluants toujours encombrants
de toute façon perdu
et pourtant prenons par exemple une
voiture flambant neuve ou mortes
elle contient exactement la même
quantité de métal et on en manque
alors il faut sortir du trou remonter la
chaîne récupérés selon le savait mais
pour qu'on commence à le faire il
fallait que cela devienne rentable que
la matière récupérée reviennent moins
cher que la matière neuf aujourd'hui
pour des quantités de produit ce rapport
le prix est en train de basculer toute
l'économie se mette à loucher vers ses
propres déchets
aujourd'hui fabriqué à acheter du neuf
coûte terriblement cher on re découvre
les bienfaits de l'objet qui dure et en
quelques années le progrès brutale du
marché de l'occasion et de la réparation
automobiles en témoigne partout on
cherche ce qui peut encore servir
petit profit individuel mais qui
débouche sur l'intérêt collectif
pourtant en dehors de l'automobile la
récupération pour le réemploi reste très
marginal la france en est encore au
stade du marché aux puces tous ces
petits revendeurs chineurs brocanteurs
se cantonne dans quelques catégories
d'objets que doublure ce qui serait
précieux pour l'économie où est par
exemple l'électroménager où sont les
huiles de vidange
ces lacunes arrange bien les affaires de
ceux qui vendent du neuf mais ils
coûtent cher au pays
et puis il ya tous les produits qu'on ne
peut plus réutiliser tel quel ils
contiennent une richesse formidable
ainsi ce que l'on a tous les jours sous
les yeux les ordures ménagères dans ce
cas un premier avantage ça brûle on peut
récupérer de la chaleur donc de
l'énergie
les usines d'incinération en témoigne
qui à paris avec trois usines seulement
fournissent 30% du chauffage urbain plus
de 90% des ordures ménagères parisienne
sont incinérés mais le reste du pays est
loin d'être équipé de façon aussi
complète pour les petites villes
l'investissement est lourd et la
rentabilité incertaine
pourtant les déchets en brûlant ne
fournissent pas seulement de la chaleur
il laisse des scories du verre des
métaux que l'on commence à savoir
extraire de l'échelle étant donné que
l'incinération est surtout pratiquée
dans les grandes villes sera déjà limité
aux grandes villes et parmi ces grandes
villes divisant pu les plus grandes
auront le plus de chances de présenter
les rentabilités les meilleurs autrement
dit en france il s'agira essentiellement
de la région parisienne
la région rhône hall et de certaines
agglomérations en france
c'est donc une question d'échelle mais
le prix de l'énergie et des matières
premières continuent de monter alors
plus le temps passera et plus nous pouv
elles deviendront rentables
les ordures ménagères suppose de
transformation complexe et des
investissements assez lourd pour
d'autres déchets au contraire peu de
transformation il s'agit surtout de les
ramasser
ainsi les chiffons les vieux papiers qui
referont facilement de la pâte à papier
et surtout les ferrailles
il n'y a pas de minerais plus riche
qu'un morceau de ferraille et en
l'absence d'organismes publics dans un
marché d'une liberté totale
les ferrailleurs ans depuis longtemps
édifier un réseau très puissant mépris
sentent absolument libre et correspondre
et nos frais uniquement uniquement et
donc des futures y ont mis un train des
accords de prix l'échelon du négoce
il est évident que c'est un marché très
fluctuant comme tout marché de matières
premières donc un caractère spéculatif
vous avez comme la france et serait que
faire en droit en matière de ferraille
plus de 6 millions de tonnes
ainsi près du quart de l'acier français
ne vient pas des mines mais de la
récupération alors si l'on se mettait à
récupérer industriellement non seulement
les métaux mais tout le reste
ces métropoles comme paris en prenant le
grand paris ça fait sans doute dix
millions d'habitants
il doit y avoir des millions de tonnes
qui se trouve ou dans les greniers ou
dans les caves
c'est toujours un problème de ramassage
de collecte mais le réseau des
ferrailleurs a au moins l'avantagé
d'exister pour bien d'autres matières
premières tout reste à créer par exemple
on jette les matières synthétiques parce
qu'on les considère comme des matériaux
bon marché c'est de plus en plus faux
car on dépense beaucoup d'énergie pour
les fabriquent
alors il faut apprendre à les
retransformer en matières premières et
en usine expérimentale tout au moins cet
obstacle technique a été surmontée nous
sommes arrivés avec ce matériau de
récupération ces déchets à produire des
pièces de caractéristiques mécaniques
très voisines de pièces que le fabricant
habituellement avec un matériau liait
vous voyez j'ai entre les mains une
pièce réalisée avec exclusivement ses
déchets de matières plastiques
travailler d'après notre procédé reste à
généraliser le ramassage transformer
l'expérience en système pour cela les
incitations de l'état seront
déterminantes
actuellement nous avons un déficit en
matière première campe équivaut environ
25 milliards de francs
je pense que sur ce déficit on pourrait
dans les prochaines années
économiser environ 10 à 15 % peut-être
plus d'ailleurs enfin même ce chiffre de
10% et déjà non négligeable avec l'aide
de l'état qu'on souhaiterait plus
puissante
l'économie moderne est en train de
trouver une nouvelle ressource qu'ils
appellent des chimères du gaspillage est
révolu on a vu l'époque de l'or et puis
celle de l'or noir
on s'achemine maintenant vers l'or des
poubelles le temps pour terminer ce
journal est très rapidement car nous
avons un tout petit peu de retard il a
fait plutôt chaud aujourd'hui avec 25
degrés à marseille 26 à biarritz et à
pau il y aura pas mal de vent pendant le
week-end du vent du sud donc à prévoir
de belles éclaircies de l'est aux alpes
et à la corse ainsi qu au pied des
pyrénées
partout ailleurs des averses des orages
et des pluies abondantes sur le massif
central
voilà pour le temps avec toute la
rédaction d'antenne 2 je vous remercie
d'avoir suivi cette édition du journal
bonsoir et tout de suite le rappel des
principaux titres de l'actualité
pas de vaincu pour la première joute
télévisée soutien du cnpf en dépit du
blocage des prix les blancs contraint de
partager le pouvoir
bientôt peut-être la communion pour les
divorcés dernier journal 22 heures
françaises
elle